oui
et
et il ya gamin de vanille la france
comporte des victoires et se battent a
vu la section rien hein
la plante on les met pas en valeur
aujourd'hui des records comme ça ça
mériterait d'être connue d'être d'être
reçus par tout le monde parce que c'est
pas seulement
c'est pas seulement des sportifs fada
qui ont envie de se surpasser
c'est une vraie école la lys et des
exemples a montré tout le monde
ouais c'est quoi votre secret alors pour
gagner voilà ténacité c'est un sport
aussi c'est un sport qu'on peut faire
vieux aussi paraît tout ce que j'ai
perdu en force physique
j'ai gagné en connaissant de lecture de
la mer moi je comprends ce qui va se
passer
et pour en savoir autant que moi il faut
avoir passé autant de temps à oui il ya
il ya des moments où moi je reçois un
bulletin météo chez qui se sont plantés
sait que c'est là qu'il faut passer du
marensin ce port mahon ces accords faut
vraiment être tenace faut être endurant
pourrait toutefois être à peu près à
mourir bien sûr mais de combien sur ce
bateau là on est sept
on est sept en permanence et on prend
des étrangers et 12 sur l'australien on
est un japonais
on est assez marrante mais bon elle
s'appelle geronimo le bateau parce que
le sponsor il s'y retrouve pas là avance
appelé le fleury michon herta saucisson
justin bridou d'abord c'est parce que
j'ai deux partenaires à et capgemini et
schneider electric 1 et en plus c'est
que étant tous les deux au cac 40 au
début je ne savais pas trop bien si vous
voulez monter daniel non bateau et tout
donc on a pris un accord n'a plus le nom
d'un d'un dash et indiens respecta très
bon qui circulait pas mais c'était un
peu c'est ce qu'on leur avait vendu et
moi je leur avais dit qu il m'a posé la
question si on aussi ont des partenaires
et où que je trop rigide il ya que des
risques 1
nous on va tous les risques que des
riverains donc on peut prendre que des
coups mais si vous
si vous êtes autre chose que les les
lopettes nenê c'est quand même un beau
métier d'homme 1 et onu ils n'ont pas
lâché mais ils sont contents ce que la
rue dans l'année la entre le tour
l'australie l'un des vieux record qui
sont souvent attaqués comme los angeles
honolulu
osaka japon on les retourne bien
cartonné toute l'année mais pour nous
c'est gratifiant
donc tu fais ça tu es obligé de grosses
têtes en plus c'est quand même le grand
avantage
enfin la grosse tête je n'en dirai pas
trop de mal parce que ça m'a quand même
nourrir prend des années mais ne suis
pas moins peu facho faire et tant mieux
si arte elle me donnait la moitié de ce
qu'ils me donnaient pour pas dire ça
m'arrange à la joie mais moi j'ai cru
que tu finirais aux grosses têtes tu
vois hélas tu en train de gagner des
records c'est formidable ce qui se passe
merci lui tout à fait toucher de cette
prévention et cette pensée qu à mon
égard ben on on dirait de chose de bien
plus dramatique ce règlement c'est
dangereux tu te crois qu'un jour ça peut
moi je suis le seul survivant de ma
génération c'est beaucoup plus dangereux
que tous les autres sports tu mets pas
en balance la sécurité la vitesse jamais
tu choisis toujours l'option qui va le
plus vite
ouais ouais mais le monde a changé le
monde météorologique a changé au fil que
depuis 97 dans le la planète elle et
c'est bon je sais pas si elle serait
chose que quand les mecs eux disent
qu'elle se réchauffe
j'aimerais voir à quel terme en bêtes
ils ont mesuré à 100 tant que quand j'ai
eu les couilles ce qu'on a déjà nous
suel cuisson carbone à degrés près on
bafouille tout ça mais ça c'est un autre
sujet mais le le les tempêtes sont plus
fortes
elecam sont plus longs comme si
l'ensemble des systèmes météorologiques
mondiaux dont les dessus tout en avaient
perdu leur tempérance et les
les attaques de mer qu'on a parfois ça
arrive d'un coup ça fait 70 245 km heure
ça lève une merde en faire tout casser
c'est brutal quoi le système les
systèmes météorologiques sont devenues
ou absence de vent ou apparition du vent
énormément de brutalité un peu de temps
mais cassius clay dix minutes ça abîme
alors olivier vous êtes ici également ce
soir pour un livre qui s'appelle la
bretagne vue de la mer aux éditions du
cherche midi
est ce qu'elle veut de la mer 7,6 chiant
la bretelle chic ou faute à ce métier
ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent me faire
arrêter qui va arrêter prématurément il
veut te dire non mais comprend le
champion car bretagne la bretagne puisse
te faire chier toi hein mais moi je suis
du midi c'est pour ça non mais même si
je jouais si ça demande des qualités
intellectuelles que tu possèdes
peut-être pas exactement quelle était
cette avancée de roche dans la mer l'un
des plus beaux océans du monde c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait
exceptionnel mais que ça t'intéresse pas
mais je comprends fort bien je t'en veux
pas pour ça donc fait partie avec un
aquarelliste qui s'appelle michel
bellion vous ai fait du cabotage
artistique on prend les côtes tels que
seuls les marins les voies et olivier je
voulais que nos mères nos femmes et nos
filles puissent partager notre regard
presque sur le lamer j'ai bien cru que
vient de dire des propos délicat sur la
bretagne
ouais je sais rien plein c'est un
miracle mais d'accord je distille une
pause bisous olivier non la mer quand tu
que tu as sur une terre la terre c'est
toujours une ombre 1
c'est une langue qui ressemble à ces
accros qui en fait c'est jamais une
couleur c'est toujours un dessin c'est
tout à coup d'horizon qui est plat il ya
une bosse qui est différente de celle
des autres c'est ça la river ouais cette
terre nous vu de la mer c'est le code
du monde qui naviguent la plupart des
gens qui payent la mer il à peine du
board du g20 sur le sur la terre ils
feignent la mère et moi je voulais on
est un gars qui fasse que chez les
navigateurs dans le temps qu'ils fassent
le croquis des atterrages vers le profit
des approches que j regarde la terre vue
de la mer notre monde
c'est un métier très important c'est ça
métier séculaire